Well, it's a perfect day then.
Yeah.
I was so confused because Seth wasn't like showing up and I'm like, what's going on? How are you, Seth?
Ohh.
I.
Yeah.
Good, how are you?
Doing well, doing well.
Oh, sorry about missing our last meeting. I took some days off and I sent a like proposed new time, but apparently that didn't go through or something. So I apologize for that.
How have you been, sir?
It's okay, because that goes to a shared calendar and that's why. From next time you can just send me an email like reschedule this meeting or schedule it for a later time and I can do that.
Ohh.
Perfect, okay, will do.
OK, how you said, how are the things going on?
They're doing going well, I think.
I don't know. I know Sahil sent me some information or like trying to help build some scripts. I'm really excited that he's attempting or doing that. I sent him back my thoughts. Hopefully he's taken those and kind of rebuilding or building upon those.
So yeah, I really love the just the thought and because I want the whole team thinking in that way. How can we make our processes better? Because I don't work them every day. Like I don't do the tickets every day. So I need the team to kind of surface those. And I love that. So yeah.
The.
Yes.
Um...
I'll keep encouraging that. So yeah, I mean, from that perspective, everything's going well.
Vaid.
And they are the first line of defense and they know the best things.
Yeah, and then I can help him kind of see like, yeah, like in the Sahil example of his scripts, like there was a couple things that wouldn't have made sense in the long term. So it was like, hey, if we do it this way, it would make sense. So yeah, I definitely love it.
We'll keep working towards that.
Sure.
We'll align you what bits you think.
Yeah.
Okay, let me start the screen sharing session. So, agenda stays the same, highlights, performance analysis, quality calendar and recap. So, we can see good on improvement in ownership and responsiveness from both the technicians, Shell and Sahil.
and they are sharing their ideas of improvement. We just discussed about that, but...
They were also sharing some concerns with me and I said like, okay, I'll take it. Like first is disk space alerts so they cannot escalate and the resolution must be done by a PA agent. And they showed me like.
PI agent does take a lot of time to work on that and fix the issue. So this is creating an issue for them, increasing the resolution time, and they are able to handle less amount of tickets. Also, they are facing some difficulty in identifying.
So...
Yeah.
So that's just not true. Escalation is no longer allowed. That statement isn't true. The guides state that. Resolution must be done via PIA agent. Resolution must be attempted with the PIA agent first, but if it doesn't work,
Okay.
We log into the machine through backstage. We look as a technician. So I guess just want to make sure that we're all aligned. Like the documents don't state that. So I guess I don't know where that like hard-coded does.
Yeah.
Okay, so what shall and Sahil, because I spoke with them in this tech was created for 8th meeting. If any change, anything changed after that, I do not know, but before 8th, they were saying like they were not allowed to escalate the tickets.
That's what they said to me. And again, this can be again a miscommunication issue.
where they understood the things incorrectly.
Yeah.
Yeah, I guess I'd be curious, like these are the kind of things that I want them to bring to me, but I'm not getting them to bring it to me, so then I'm hearing about it here when I think everything's going well. So I'm confused, that's all.
So, yeah.
Here.
No worries. What I'll do, I'll have a meeting with them on Monday. I'll explain them. If you encounter any issue or anything, we'll set up that stage where they can, they will point out all these issues and they will get the things clarified on their end.
Yeah, I mean, so here's like, so you guys understand, like, so those disk space alerts, Shale and Sahil and team explained to me that they disliked escalating all the time. They wanted to work the tickets. So now that I got them working the tickets, the issue is they can't escalate.
Correct.
So, it's a little confusing there.
Rick.
And then, you know, the whole point to the disk space alerts was, hey, you guys don't want to escalate them as much. You want to work the tickets. Okay, I agree. Like I want you guys to be able to work more and feel more ownership. So let's turn it on the flip it. I spent a good week or two building out a matrix of folders.
Correct.
on what is easy to delete and not. And then we had a meeting about this face alerts. We're like, hey guys, I gave you guys a starting point. Let's build on it because I'm not God, I can't think of all the scenarios, but like let's build on that matrix of folders that we can and can't delete.
Um...
And as a team kind of grow there. Maybe that's not the way to handle it. Maybe that was a bad decision on my end because maybe the team isn't capable of that. And maybe we need to just keep going back to having them escalate.
Yeah.
And why they're saying that they need to, they are not able to escalate because they said like it's clearly made a point that they cannot escalate and the previous ticket which they had escalated, they want to see what other steps were the senior engineers taking.
They were unable to see that because I guess the documentation, sorry, maybe the queue visibility was not there with them. And that's the reason they are unable to see. And again, the PA agent is taking time and.
I don't think.
Blake.
Once, suppose it fails and it's unable to remediate, then they log in into the backstage. They told me, and you are correct, they log in to backstage and then fix it. But yes, this takes a lot of time because first PI agent has to work on and then they need to.
to validate all the steps in that. That is what is taking time.
Oh, okay. Well, that's fine. I mean, that's T2 work. They wanted T2 work, so let's do T2 work. I mean, that's fine. I don't mind if resolution times take longer because we're doing the work. That's okay. I mean, from my perspective, and I mean, I'm open for, if that's just not what they want to do,
TT.
Yeah.
Thank you.
It.
Middha.
Like if they do just want to triage and escalate, I can have Shale and Sahil just do that.
No, no, that was not the intent. It was just they told me like they have been asked not to escalate this space tickets and we should be resolving that. That's what they said. I'm sorry if this got presented in the incorrect way to you.
Yeah.
Okay, so...
No, you're fine. I'm just trying to get to the root, try to figure it out. I mean, that's it. That's my whole point is like, let's figure out where the gaps are.
Yeah.
And then...
And yeah, like I have an issue personally with PIA, but frankly, it's out of my control. It's being pushed. We got to use it. So like.
How much longer is your contract?
Well, I mean, here's the thing though, like...
Yeah.
Previously, for like, let's use this space alert. So previously, what we were doing was going to the internet, downloading tree size, putting tree size on the machine, running tree size, and then creating a ticket for a whole other team because tree size kicks off for CrowdStrike. CrowdStrike doesn't like tree size because tree size does file operations that are bad.
Blake.
from CrowdStrike's perspective, which we can't turn those off because legitimate ransomware does the same thing that tree size does. So we stopped using tree size. So the interim was, hey, well, Pia takes a few clicks.
scans the folders because the team has not yet presented to me what they would want to use with PowerShell to bypass PIA because all PIA does is run PowerShell.
Yeah, yeah.
Burt.
So, I mean, and so far nobody, and this is kind of a little bit of a test from my perspective. Like I asked the team, hey, let's start using PIA, but let's also build a PowerShell script behind the scenes that can be used if PIA doesn't work. Maybe that was too much for the team. Maybe I just need to have a T3.
Mm.
Yeah.
Way, like...
Yeah, I'm open. I mean, I'm not trying to be, I guess, combative here. I just want to, I'm just trying to understand a little bit and then explain some of the stuff happening.
Yeah, it makes sense. And I do think the way that Seamus put on here, like escalation is currently not allowed. I'm sure that's how they communicated it to you. But realistically, it sounds like you said, you are giving them the opportunity to work on tier 2 work and you've told them not to escalate because they're going to be working on it. And I think that's just.
Um...
Yeah.
Generally, for the for the.
Well, and, and, and this, the guy doesn't, the guy that I built, I guess, I mean, maybe you guys just haven't seen this.
Yeah, is there something on there that literally is like, when is a reason for them to escalate and then that just be the like, there shouldn't be too much.
Yeah.
Yeah, like, I mean, we have.
I literally like built, so I mean, here, I'll share my screen. Where is it at?
And then Seamus for you, like who would be best to like work on this PowerShell project?
Well, that's not required. I have some disk cleanup script. I'm just finding that.
My, and so the other, like, the other thing with desk space, like...
RMM does everything that Sahil script wanted to do. So Sahil was already like just recreating the same thing that we did before the ticket was generated. He knows that.
Gotcha.
Like he's been told that a few times. But like, just to back up before we get too in the weeds, like, you know, I build a little matrix, I'm sharing my screen here, like all these, they're, you know, if you see these being used a lot, delete the folders, you don't have to escalate. But, you know, if these folders are here, escalate to care team. Like there are escalation paths outlined.
in this doc. So I just want to make sure that we're all on the same page. It doesn't mean don't escalate. It just means I want you to escalate less because you guys said you didn't want to escalate. So let's stay the course there, I guess, was the point with that whole thing. Now,
I did state, hey, if this isn't going to be exhaustive, we can't possibly make a clear every single scenario do this or do that when it comes to folders on a machine. That's impossible. But the idea was, hey, let's start here and slowly over a time accumulate knowledge.
Uhh...
Thus far, nobody suggested, not even my...
Yeah, so what I was gonna ask, I was like, has anybody put anything in here now?
No, and apparent, and to me, that's a failing on me. Like I overestimated the team, not just Sales and Shale and Sahil on like wanting to do that. Which.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's that's on me, like that's my.
That's a, yeah, and that's a, yeah, and I'm Seth, I think we're all in the same industry. I think a lot of techs will just get caught up in what they're already doing and kind of look at it as more of like a project. But yeah, I would just manage it that way. Like, hey guys, this is a project that we're working on. Like, let's have updates every week.
Yeah. So, I mean, well, and that's where Wes will have to come in. We've got, I have literally eight different projects that I'm working on outside of this team. So, like, I was really hoping, and obviously, like, I think it's not the case that, like, I'll have to have my T3s build their script.
Yeah.
for these guys to work, which is fine.
Seamus, is that what you do? Is that what we need, Seamus, though? Or can we help here? Because I bet your T3s have stuff to do as well. Like, can we take some ownership here? How do you feel about it?
Is this the script?
Okay, yeah, this is a pretty lengthy script and it does all the things.
Is this the one you were talking about, Seth, that's similar or this different?
No, this is...
This isn't, this isn't what Sahil, Sahil sent me something AI made. Let's just be totally up front there, like, so he sent me an AI script. This looks a little different.
OK.
Yeah.
I do.
Yes.
My only big thing with like any scripts that we use is a lot of the disk cleanup scripts that get spread around remove log files and folders that hinder people troubleshooting a day or two later. So our RMM removes
I...
after seven days of logs so that technicians outside of this ticket get the ability to troubleshoot without shooting ourselves in the foot. And that was one thing I brought up with Sahil, like your script just outright deletes every log file, every event viewer file.
So then, you know, technician comes in for some other issue, they just can't troubleshoot because logs are gone. But yeah, I mean, if this script, I can run the script by our RMM admins to see if it even can just be built into RMM so they could literally just click it and run it.
Yeah, and this can be an auto run as soon as the alert is triggered. So what we have been doing with other partners is that what the thing does is as soon as the alert triggers, it runs the script, it cleans out. If it gets fixed, it's okay.
That, that's an option.
But.
Yeah.
alert gets closed, ticket is not created. If it does not clean or the alert is still there, then it creates the ticket for the engineer.
That's precisely how we work too, which has been like, so to understand too, like some of the contention on Marco's end is, you know,
Kour.
When we were escalating, the other teams were just running a script like this and closing the ticket, but that doesn't solve anything. But I do know that most MSPs don't actually care, so they do just close the ticket and move on. We were trying to do something a little radical where it was like, hey, if we've got disk issues repeating and constantly happening, maybe it's a talk with the
Yeah.
client to upgrade their machines. Maybe it's a talk with the client to be like a consultive MSP trying to help their outcomes.
Okay, so are you looking for more like problem management results from them?
No, not today, because it's just not a capability of the team. That would be lovely in the future, but I'm not expecting, like it was meant to be kind of like a piecemeal, like, okay, hey, I built, you know, we built the first iteration. Let's as a team, you know, hey, like Sahil ran into a folder.
Yeah.
Let's send a message to our teams chat and say, hey guys, have you guys ran into this before? Is this a folder that's okay to delete? If the team's like, yes, then let's add it to the matrix. After 2 weeks, that hasn't happened yet. So my plan was, you know, after a month of this new disk space alert being in there,
having a meeting, saying, hey, like what have we found after a month? We're just not totally there yet.
But yeah, I mean, that script that you shared, I mean, I can definitely see if it overlaps with what RMM is already doing. RMM has, I think it's a 2 or 3000 line disk cleanup script that it runs before a ticket's created. So like.
We're pretty well there already, so like the disk space cleanup after was meant.
Maybe.
you know, to give the opportunity to be a consultative, like opportunity for either the engineers. Like I have an engineer, Tyler, who does, in 15 minutes handles those disk space alerts, reaches out to the client, says, hey, these are the folders you need to delete. Please let me know when you delete them. And then moves on.
I'm trying to get that information into a guide. And that's, you know, where we're working towards. So there's a lot of work that I guess I need to do on my end now that I'm hearing what you guys are telling me from the engineers.
But.
Yeah, so do we just need to figure out what Tyler is doing and replicate it?
Well, Tyler's just looking at it and saying, oh, OneDrive taking up everything. Let me call the user.
Gotcha, gotcha, so it's a...
I mean, because it is frankly like a, it's a, these tickets at this point with how RMM handles them.
Like ideal state would be there mostly just to call the client and say, hey, you got this, your OneDrive downloads are like 40 gigs. Can you clean that up? We can't, like we can't just go delete a user's downloads. We got to reach out. And I, that, so yeah, I mean, that's.
And are you want you want our engineers to do that too? That's what the expectation is.
If they're capable.
I think they should be Seamus.
Yeah.
They are capable of calling back the users, and they can analyze this, but again...
I mean...
Yeah.
Go ahead.
Yeah, but again, they would be doing that to tree size because analyzing the folders and everything and that's where you come into picture to clarify this out. How is Tyler doing that cleanup or how is he analyzing that?
This disk is taking a lot of time. Sorry, this folder is taking up a lot of space.
He's going on the machine through backstage and just looking.
Yeah, so it sounds like it will probably say that it's the same amount over and over. Is that what it looks like? I don't know, not technical. Like what is, what is, I guess, what are the triggers he's looking for? And that's where Seamus is asking.
and or using PIA.
The triggers, I guess, yeah, I'd have to ask him. It's from experience. That's it. I mean,
Yeah.
But I guess, like, this is all kind of, this is enlightening. So I guess ultimately, like...
We need to have another few meetings about this space alerts to really talk about like what the expectations here because it seems like there might be a little bit of translation issue on my end. I'll own that like this space alerts.
I mean, I've talked to a few other MSPs of our size. They are just a burden to everybody. Most MSPs, after a certain point, just turn it off. But...
Perfect.
That's dangerous, right? Well, I guess you can say, as long as you're looking to see where the level's at, right? You just have to...
Those have.
Not really, it.
Well, yeah, like turning it off, the ramifications are then the team would get more Windows Update failure alerts.
Yeah.
and you lose one or the other. But ultimately, I think I understand where we need to go. Yeah, like if they want to help build scripts, I was hoping like kind of the pipe dream, it sounds like, was that then they would feel empowered to take the time to do that.
and offer up improvements as the team.
That's, you know, it's only been a month or like close to a month. So I mean, it's still a little early to really answer that, but I think I'm starting to see that answer a little bit, which is likely having other engineers on other teams build the script and give them the script to run, which is okay. I kind of wondered if that was one of the routes we'd have to go.
And then also I'll work on making it a little more clear in the doc, like you are okay to escalate if you just don't know, but let's escalate to the team first before we escalate to other teams. And outlining that a little bit more so that they can.
Sure.
You know, work these a little bit more efficiently, I guess, but...
I mean, yeah, I think that's where I'm gonna go with that a little bit.
Okay, for the windows.
Phelps.
Seamus, would it make sense for like, is that the Bureau okay with it? If Seamus kind of jumps in there too, just so we can make sure that I know like on your side, they're doing what they need to do, but just so we can add that additional layer. And then we have firsthand information instead of having to go through the layers.
Sure.
Yeah, I mean, I like they have the guides in IT glue. Sometimes I question if they even look at the guides because of some of the responses that I get. But they are like they have permissions in IT glue. They've been shared those docs.
I'll take this up with them, no worries for them set. I'll take this up and I'll explain them.
Yeah, okay.
You should see an improvement, OK, for.
Well...
And I'll own some of that. Like, this is new. We're trying to make it better. So, I mean, it's not, there's no like docking of points, so to speak, from my end. Like, these guys are doing great. Like, there's just room for improvement on everybody's end, not just Shale and Sahil. Like, the whole team, there's some room there.
Kour.
So...
Yeah.
Okay, and for Windows feature, they said like there was some process that was being changed and they had not at that time the process was not there. The process was still being written how to handle these tickets because there are a lot of machines which are...
Yep.
offline which are offline from a very long time and they do not know what to do and the tickets sitting there for a long time.
Yeah.
They, well, so the escalation bit, yes. There is a whole bunch of stuff that they can do prior to escalation. It is very well outlined in the procedure.
The escalation to care teams, yes, that has been paused much to my frustration in multiple meetings with other teams. But frankly, like the reality was our team, so Shale, Sahil, all my other guys were escalating the tickets to another team.
That other team has decided that their engineers are not worthy of working on these tickets, so they were just sending them back. That is not OK from my perspective, but that's where we're kind of at. So for now, yes, it is a.
work what we can. Yes, there is a small subset of machines that are offline. There is about 10% of the 500 tickets for this that are offline. If they're offline, it's a very simple ticket.
emailing the point of contact saying, hey, can you turn this machine on? Moving on to the next ticket. So yeah, those are a little, those are frustrating for me right now. But a lot of those feature update failures, yes, they're offline or just like,
They need BIOS updates or things that this team that is under me has articulated they are not willing to do, which would require, and it frankly can't really be done remotely. A BIOS update is probably not something we should be doing without a little bit of hands-on.
So, so yeah, I mean, this is kind of the state that we're at with Windows feature updates until I can figure out a better way to make that work.
with those. So yeah, there's nothing they're doing wrong there. That is all Marco Helpdesk design at scale.
Okay.
I do have just because we're talking, sorry, I know, Seamus, we're, you want to get into this piece and we're towards the end. So is your RMM, everything's like centralized? Have we done like a health check for you or anything like that where we can actually kind of look at the RMM as a whole and just we have a different team?
Moving on.
not just these guys, they can still do what they're doing, but I like we do that for free here at ITBD. So us talking about it just made me think about it.
What would the health, what's the health check do? Like, I mean, we're moving from automate to ConnectWise RMM. We're getting rid of Kaseya and automate. Like, what would you guys want to do? Because I mean, we have, yeah.
Okay.
Well...
Yeah, we would help set like we do, we can help set up with the migration as well if you're like switching over and then we would just make sure that like all the boards or give recommendations on how you can set it up.
Would it be the same type of...
Because typically we would go in, yeah, and look at where you're at right now, but if you're setting up a new one, then it may it may be different.
I'll talk with Dennis and the RMM admins. I mean, RMM admins. Yeah, I mean, we've got 36,000 endpoints that we're managing.
Yeah.
And we are mid-migration. We've got about 2,500 hours over the last year on the ticket for the migration because we are rebuilding from the ground up every automation.
Inbound.
So, yeah, I mean, I...
Yeah, let us let us know if you guys want to even just try to move it a little quicker. We have a whole capable team that we've done those migrations.
Yeah, we're not trying to move quickly. It's more, there seems to be a lot, like even Marco thinks that there's always these improvements to the scripting, but every time we get scripting suggestions, it's a regression in the current scripting. So I'm wary of just having, like letting anybody in.
Yeah.
Um, but I'll let me, I'll talk with Dennis and the team about that a little bit.
Yeah, just let us know. That one's just a brief, and then we would just let you know what it would look like. Oh, now Seamus performance. Go ahead. It's over to you.
Yeah.
No worries. Overall, the utilization is going good. Average utilization is at 98%.
Moving our next ticket close. So overall this looks good. No issues. Looks pretty steady.
Yeah, awesome.
And no upcoming holidays, I guess the next one is coming on 3rd July. Nothing before that.
Phelps.
Yep, that looks about right.
Okay, that's the end. And thanks Seth for speaking up so openly. I'll share that script with you. Then I'll share the MOM and then you can see if any points are missed and then you can add that script. You can add that in the script and you can also review the script if.
You need anything?
Okay, yeah, I'd be curious. I'll have, if you can share the script with me, I'll share it with the admins, because we already have a disk cleanup script that the teams encourage to run. That so far, a lot of people aren't, some are. So there's already a script that they could use.
It might need to be more defined in the guide. It's in there, but not maybe as bolded as it could be. But yeah, cool. That sounds like a plan.
Sure. Sameer is here. Hi, Sameer. You want to add on anything?
Nothing.
Thank you.
No, it's a typical NOC work, Shashank. I think you and me, we need to connect. I think a lot more data sets we can share with set. It's pure NOC the way we do for the shared NOC services. I'll work with you on showing what else we can show.
Like, um...
Kip.
Yeah.
That's what I feel like.
Cool.
Okay, yeah, I mean, share with me what you guys want to propose there. I mean, I can't guarantee anything, but yeah.
Dharam.
Yeah.
No, no, no, it's just a value add. It's just a value add set, right? Because we run a very big NOC where we have like customers who have around 6,000 endpoints, 10,000 endpoints on the NOC side as well. So we do have some scripts, of course, we can send it over to you for your suggestions. Also on the RM side, we're Natalie saying.
No, that, yeah, yeah.
We have built multiple clients, PSS, RMM services as well from scratch. So we do have the automation data as well and also a good set of folks who can help you from the health check perspective and also understand where you're going from one to another. Right, so that's the idea.
Nothing that we want to implement or add or anything. Of course, I know how Marco works, right? So I completely understand that piece.
Yeah, we just have resources that can support the engineers and what they're doing right now too. So I just want to help you.
Yeah, yeah, we're kind of on the end, Sprint. Like we're on June 1st, every Marco tech's getting access to ConnectWise RMM. June 4th is when we're flipping policies and patching from automate to RMM. Now granted, 740 clients
And it, you know, we're doing it purposefully slow so that when we do the new policy and the patching, when we move it from automate to RMM, it's just done correctly. So yeah, I mean.
Well, I'll talk with the team; we'll go from there.
Yeah, no problem. No, we are open for suggestions. Also, if you feel like whatever the tweaks and things that Seamus can do or Shashank can do with the team, I think you are transparent enough to share with us, so we are good there.
Mum.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Thank you. Have a good day. Thank you, Satyaveer.
Thanks. Have a great day. Thanks. Bye.
Thanks, everybody. Yeah.
Yes.